the picturesque market town of stafford
is not the place you would associate
with gang activity
but thanks to covered vulnerable young
people in quiet corners like this
are falling into the hands of the county
line's drug trade
during lockdown i didn't want to be at
home i was always arguing and fighting
with my parents
i went out all the time to avoid them i
was bored
and lonely we can't tell you alicia's
real name as it would put her at risk
and her words have been revoiced but
she's just 14 years old and struggled
with her mental health during lockdown
when an 18 year old boy messaged her on
snapchat she thought it could be the
start of an exciting new relationship
i met him on snapchat he added me and we
just started talking
he persuaded me to meet him so i did and
he seemed really nice
but things quickly changed alicia was in
the clutches of a county lines gang
forced to run drugs carry weapons and
have sex
whenever we'd meet up we'd smoke weed
together he always had some
he owed money to his dealer and i owed
money to him
he said i could pay it back by working
for him i got offered free phones and
free weed and other stuff as well as
that
i said i wouldn't do it anymore once i'd
paid it back but then i got offered more
free weed so i just carried on
i'd seen other people get beaten up or
threatened or have their houses smashed
if they said no
so i couldn't it got worse pretty
quickly
he'd get people to sit outside my house
to keep tabs on me you must wear a face
covering
he told me that if i was out when i
wasn't supposed to be
he'd put our windows through
i was never given any tickets i was just
told to jump the trains
i went locally at first then to other
cities
i'd carry the weed and sometimes coke in
a bag
my boyfriend got me working for another
guy who asked if i wanted to make some
money by packing weapons
he was higher up than the other dealers
so i felt protected
i just did the drops jump in the trains
again
i was made to have sex with some of the
guys i was worried about what would
happen if i said no
because i saw others get assaulted for
not doing stuff
[Music]
but it got to a point where i knew i was
in this really deep
i realized i needed help i didn't want
to be involved in the gang but was
worried about what would happen if i
said no
i knew it couldn't carry on a report by
the national youth agency shared
exclusively with sophie ridge on sunday
says that young people like alicia are
at risk of exploitation from county
lines gangs
more than ever the report also says the
typical victim
is changing more affluent more female
many youth workers have also reported
victims getting younger
i think we need much greater public
awareness of what's going on
sarah parker works for the local youth
charity who are now helping alicia
adjust to a new life
the impact is absolutely devastating she
says there are many more stories like
alicia's
we have seen social media being used
very widely to groom children primarily
that's that's why because
children have spent all that time online
and
and have been encouraged to education's
gone online you know their parents have
have known that
that kind of keeps them occupied it
stops them from getting bored
it means that they can remain in contact
with their friends but it also means
they can be in contact with with other
people
but we've also seen social media um
being used to advertise job
opportunities for
children to make quick money um so
actually some of the kind of the roles
in county lines exploitation have been
advertised
i mean take the example of alicia she is
in no way
what you would consider to be a
traditional victim of county lines
exploitation
she's a girl to start with she comes
from
[Music]
a settled loving and economically stable
home um and and yet she's been drawn
into this this terrible situation that's
had a huge impact
both on her and on her family um so yeah
i think we're seeing there's kind of
been a much wider range of children have
been
targeted in drawing youth workers and
charities across the country have told
sky news they've seen more girls in
particular
being exploited by county lines gangs
during the pandemic
now politicians like the chair of the
parliamentary group on knife crime
are also worried if you're talking about
girls
caught up in county lines they're not
part of a gang they are victims of gangs
and unless we look at it from a gendered
approach we won't
address this issue and one of the key
things
that we also need to look at is the data
we're still we're still unclear about
how many young women and girls are
caught up in this
activity the police may say they've had
a great year in in terms of arrest
but it's not a great year when at the
end of this you're seeing
women and girls still being exploited
you're seeing women and girls being
violently raped by gang members
you're seeing women and girls probably
stash in some of these drugs
and weapons in their properties
endangering other family members
so that's not a great success linux
rogers a former gang member himself
now works with young people who need
help turning away from life in a gang
his phone hasn't stopped ringing during
lockdown
we talked to a lot of people we needed
to
get out there and help young people and
the families address these issues
there were some young people that we
worked with
who were working their shifts got
reduced
in covid and so it had an
impact on their finances and and
they had some friends some of whom were
negative
influences and they were introduced
to drugs you know and they were showing
them oh you know you could have this you
could have that
and it was very tempting covid um
you know increased their business
because um people were struggling to
cope with mental health issues
and they use drugs to cope with escapism
and you know i noticed
quite a few young people that we're new
to it
thousands of children are exploited by
county lines gangs across the uk
each year luckily for alicia she got
help
but the road to recovery is a long one
i'm finally getting some help
i'm listening to people i'm trying to
get my life back but it's really hard